bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct notre grand témoin ce soir nous
emmène à Calais aux côtés des migrants
qui rêvent de l'Angleterre bonsoir Julia
goodychaud et merci d'être là vous êtes
journaliste indépendant vous publiez
avec Nicolas torrent les plages de
lombarquement aux éditions Les Arènes
septembre vous avez passé 7 ans au côté
des migrants aux côtés des passeurs
aussi sur un cadeau de fortune car vous
l'avez faite cette traversée de la
Manche on va en parler dans ce moment où
il faut bien le dire les naufrages
mortels se multiplient dans
l'indifférence générale on en parle tous
les deux dans la deuxième partie mais on
commence ce soir par le pacte vert
européen sauver de justesse aujourd'hui
en séance plénière à Strasbourg c'était
un vote très important les députés
européens ont adopté à 36 petites voix
près de nouvelles règles pour restaurer
la biodiversité on va y revenir dans le
détail l'offensive de la droite et de
l'extrême droite échoue mais va-t-elle
laisser des traces notamment en 2024 aux
élections européennes grands débat dans
un instant avec nos invités sur ce
plateau avant de retrouver 20h15 des
affranchis pour leur parti pris et puis
Bourbon Express bien sûr l'histoire du
jour à l'Assemblée voilà pour le menu on
y va Nicolas gaudichaud
[Musique]
les défenseurs du climat et de la
biodiversité en Europe peuvent souffler
ce soir l'Union de la Droite et de
l'extrême droite n'est pas majoritaire
au Parlement européen mais ce qui s'est
passé à Strasbourg mérite concis à
Rennes à 36 voix seulement les députés
ont adopté la loi de restauration de la
nature que prévoit-elle on va y revenir
c'est l'une des pièces du grand puzzle
du pacte vert qui donne le la en Europe
à la transition écologique bonsoir
Anne-Laure Blin et merci d'être là vous
êtes député les républicains du
Maine-et-Loire le Parti populaire
européen a voté dans sa très large
majorité et donc vos collègues à
Strasbourg contre ce projet de loi on se
demande un peu pourquoi ça mérite une
explication bonsoir Cécile claveyrol
bienvenue vous êtes Secrétaire National
de France Nature Environnement bonsoir
Anne-Claire Poirier merci d'être là vous
êtes journaliste indépendante
spécialisés sur les questions de
transition écologique et elle arrive de
Strasbourg dès que voilà elle aura mis
un pied sur la gare sur le quai de gare
parisien elle est un peu en retard car
il m'a délivan nous rejoindre elle est
député européenne écologiste je vous ai
appelé Nicolas autant pour moi Julien
godicho soyez le bienvenu dans ce débat
vous êtes journaliste vous pouvez même
interroger c'est un débat un peu
technique mais à Fort en géopolitique
nos invités au féminin pluriel ce soir
on va commencer par l'ami black opski
que s'est-il passé aujourd'hui le film
de la journée au Parlement européen
pourquoi ce vote était crucial le chrono
de Blacko tout de suite
et je me retourne pour vous accueillir
je vous invite à faire la même chose
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir à toutes et
tous alors qu'est-ce qui s'est passé à
Strasbourg
ni pour son ambiance festive ni pour son
côté chaleureux et pourtant aujourd'hui
regardez explosion de joie dans les
mises cycle vous allez voir les images
on voit rarement ça des gens qui se
jettent dans les bras mais c'est parce
qu'on a adopté donc la loi de
restauration de la nature et les gens en
sont à la fois heureux et soulagés parce
qu'on n'était pas sûr que la doit serait
adoptée pourtant l'objectif de la loi il
est tout à fait louable il s'agit donc
de préserver restaurer si possible la
biodiversité donc j'imagine que vous
êtes au courant qu'il y a un problème
avec la biodiversité donc je vous ai
choisi l'exemple des oiseaux qui sont
des animaux plus sympathiques en tout
cas pour le grand public que les
insectes voyez 25% c'est le la
diminution de la population des oiseaux
décident depuis 40 ans quand on parle de
certains oiseaux comme ceux qui vivent
dans les champs aura du sol exposé aux
pesticides c'est moins 60% dans les
effectifs alors avec cette loi
l'objectif c'est que chaque pays vient
de voir restaurer ces écosystèmes qui
ont été abîmés donc il sera des seuils à
atteindre comme souvent ces cas-là 30%
en 2030 60 % 2040 et pour arriver 90%
des écosystèmes restaurés ce qui était
abîmé en tout cas en 2050 alors on se
demande pourquoi s'opposer un objectif
aussi louable en fait le principal
opposant au Parlement européen c'est le
PPE le Parti populaire européen c'est le
plus gros groupe parlementaire à
Strasbourg et regroupe en gros les élus
de droite et du sang pour vous donner
une idée en France chez LR et une partie
des centristes qui icigent alors ce qui
inquiète le PPE c'est l'idée que cette
loi puisse avoir un des conséquences sur
la production agricole s'inquiète
d'autant plus qu'on a vu l'an dernier
avec l'invasion de l'Ukraine que il peut
y avoir effectivement des aspects de de
prix sur l'alimentaire qui était très
inquiétant c'est ce qui explique Manfred
Weber qui est donc le patron du PP de
Strasbourg
la Commission met sur la table une loi
dont elle dit elle-même dans l'étude
d'impact qu'elle conduira à une baisse
de la production de nourriture en Europe
ce n'est pas le bon moment de faire
cette loi alors ce matin à Strasbourg il
y avait comme souvent les groupes de
pression les plus motivés qui
s'affrontaient bon c'était un peu
caricatural du coup on avait d'un côté
Greta Thunberg avec les écolos radicaux
qui faisaient face aux syndicat
agricoles qui eux vous le voyez avait
déplacé les tracteurs donc en réalité
l'objet de cette loi n'est pas vraiment
soutenu par l'écologie radicale c'est ce
que Pascal qu'enfin qui lui est un élu
Renaissance qui est président de la
commission de l'environnement a essayé
d'expliquer aux élus du PPE il leur dit
quand même dans le fond vous êtes des
gens raisonnable on l'écoute si vous ne
voulez pas écouter les scientifiques
unanimes pour défendre la nécessité de
cette loi alors écoutez la Fédération
européenne des chasseurs
les chasseurs sont favorables à cette
loi ecoutez les entreprises du secteur
de l'agroalimentaire qui sont favorables
à cette loi ecouter la Banque centrale
européenne qui nous rappelle que
l'immense majorité de notre économie et
dépendante des services rendus par la
nature alors quand on entend ça on se
dit mais est-ce que le PPE n'aura pas
une autre idée derrière la tête en
s'opposant à cette loi parce que vous
savez dans un an ce sont les élections
européennes or ces dernières années
qu'est-ce qu'on a vu bien que la droite
pouvait saler dans certains pays comment
se fait en Italie avec les nationalistes
avec l'extrême droite pour atteindre le
pouvoir donc l'exemple c'est celui de
l'Italie troisième pays de l'Union ou de
gens jamais le Nice est allié avec Forza
Italia donc le parti de feu Berlusconi
qui lui est un parti qui appartient au
PPE alors est-ce que manfon Bever n'a
pas une idée derrière la tête le
décryptage de Pascal Campin
il y a une partie de la droite menée par
le leader du Parti populaire européen
Manfred Weber qui fait le pari que
demain l'Europe pourrait être dirigé par
une coalition allant de l'extrême droite
au centre droit il veut faire de ce
texte le laboratoire de cette majorité
alternative alors si c'était intéressant
pour voir la validité de l'Union des
droites on va dire c'est raté ce coup-ci
mais n'empêche le débat est là parce que
les élections européennes c'est dans un
an et cette idée du nom des droites à
mon avis elle n'a pas fini de faire son
chemin merci beaucoup Stéphane je vais
commencer avec vous à nordblin qu'est-ce
que vous répondez à Pascal confin qui au
fond vous dit la droite a voulu faire un
coup politique l'Union des droites
finalement pour des raisons plus
politiques voire idéologiques que sur le
fond véritablement de ce projet de loi
ce n'est pas un coup politique
ce projet de loi qui s'appelle
restauration de la nature c'est pas une
restauration de la nature c'est une mise
en oeuvre de la décroissance et c'est ce
que a défendu justement parce que les
agriculteurs c'est la décroissance
clairement sur quoi et ça va clairement
à l'encontre du climat aujourd'hui les
agriculteurs sont les premiers
défenseurs de la biodiversité sont les
premiers protecteurs de l'environnement
avec ce texte on va geler des
territoires agricoles entièrement parce
que au nom d'une idéologie pro
environnement en tout cas prétendument
pro environnement on sacrifie nos
agriculteurs qui eux font tout pour
protéger la nature et c'est une
problématique parce qu'on l'a vu la
guerre en Ukraine le covid la crise
énergétique a démontré que cette
idéologie d'extrême gauche et des
écologistes qui sont en réalité des des
partisans de l'écologie punitive
et c'est à force de lobby à démobiliser
les agriculteurs et surtout à leur
envoyer des messages qui leur dit qu'en
fait ce qu'ils font pour maintenir notre
souveraineté alimentaire sur le
territoire ne sert à rien alors il y a
beaucoup de choses dans tout ce que vous
dites
donc c'est loin d'être un coup politique
vous parlez beaucoup de choses tuer les
agriculteurs sacrifie on a envie aussi
les vrais budgets pour la souverain on
voit bien que c'est la question agricole
qui a cristallisé les enjeux je vous
propose déjà de revoir un peu le face à
face Greta Thunberg qui était donc avec
les militants écologistes devant le
Parlement européen et puis là on les
voit les militants et puis juste à côté
le même jour cette colonne de tracteur
des agriculteurs qui eux aussi sont
venus mettre la pression pendant ces
deux jours de débat à Strasbourg on va
écouter Christiane Lambert elle aussi à
la denture elle représente les
agriculteurs contre ce texte
depuis des années nous avons réduit
l'usage des produits phytosanitaires
nous avons réduit l'usage des
antibiotiques nous avons fait changer
nos pratiques aussi nous captons plus de
carbone nous pratiquons le nom labour
pour avoir plus de biodiversité dans les
sols bref nous changeons nos pratiques
mais une loi autoritaire descendante qui
veut fixer des règles homogènes pour
tous les pays ça n'est pas acceptable
c'est cycles avérol c'est vraiment la
question agricole qui a cristallisé les
oppositions si on doit retenir un
élément de fond on viendra aux questions
politiques avec la perspective des
élections de 2024 après la droite on
entendait madame Blin explique que -10%
de surfaces agricoles pour laisser un
peu en jachère pour construire des haies
pour préserver la nature la biodiversité
ce serait au fond tuer l'agriculture
qu'est-ce que vous répondez alors tout
ça il faut tous les arguments sont faux
on n'a pas diminué les pesticides on les
a augmenté de 15% depuis 2009 d'accord
le raisonnement qui est toute chose
égale par ailleurs on continue comme
maintenant et on continue avec les
pesticides les engrais etc en fait ce
qu'il faut ce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est que la baisse de la biodiversité
ce sont les agriculteurs qui vont en
payer le prix dans les années qui
viennent c'est nous tous parce que parce
que c'est notre vie notre cadre de vie
mais surtout la biodiversité c'est quoi
la biodiversité dans les sols c'est la
fertilité des sols c'est avec ça qu'il
produisent c'est avec la nature qu'il
produisent c'est pas contre donc c'est
complètement des peurs qui sont agitées
alors les peurs je les comprends
parfaitement on les a emmenés depuis 60
ans dans un modèle
hyperproductiviste qui qu'il est ils
sont pieds poignée avec les banques avec
les crédits avec voilà les peurs il y a
pas de problème on peut en discuter mais
avec des normes aussi avec des mais il
faut qu'on sorte de ce de ce schéma là
et qu'on les accompagne correctement à
aller dans des nouvelles dans des
nouvelles cultures souvent nouveau mode
de production alors effectivement
Christiane cite le nom labour certes
c'est une très bonne évolution mais le
nom labour s'accompagne au glyphosate
parce que pour détruire la culture qu'on
avant puisqu'on ne labour pas on va
mettre du glyphosate voilà c'est des
choses comme ça que l'on mais il y a ce
qu'il faut voir aussi c'est qu'il y a
des agriculteurs qui aujourd'hui font
différemment il faut se baser sur leur
pour vous il y a beaucoup plus de
crainte que de véritablement de
contraintes bon alors Karima délire on a
choisi un petit compromis on voulait
absolument vous avoir en direct dans
cette émission donc on a on a choisi de
vous avoir par Skype parce que sinon ça
aurait été trop juste merci d'être là
vous avez vécu toute cette journée de
vote important à l'assemblé à
l'Assemblée mais au Parlement européen à
Strasbourg déjà 36 voix c'est peu est-ce
que vous pouvez parler véritablement de
victoire ce soir
en fait c'est un texte on peut parler de
victoire symbolique mais pour nous c'est
vraiment une défaite aussi pour Monsieur
Weber qui a qui n'a pas réussi son pari
de créer une nouvelle alliance avec
l'extrême droite en vue des prochaines
élections européennes
ce texte est véritablement un texte fort
et fondateur parce qu'il fait partie un
des leviers d'action du pacte vert donc
pour nous il était très très important
et il montre aussi qu'on ne peut pas
faire de pause environnementale parce
que le texte vert nous permet de rentrer
vraiment et on le voit tous les jours on
le voit encore aujourd'hui sur le double
objectif la lutte contre le dérèglement
climatique mais surtout la protection de
la de la biodiversité et vous avez dit
un petit peu quelques mots qui parce que
j'ai entendu auparavant je voudrais dire
que la loi qui a été
volonté a été quand même accompagnée de
fake news assez incroyable
c'est-à-dire précisément par exemple on
a pu entendre que par exemple dans le
texte on prévoyait de geler 10% des
terres agricoles c'est absolument faux
que le PPE a dit
que par exemple ce week-end alors
tenez-vous bien tenez vous bien le PPE
donc le Parti conservateur donc la
droite de ce Parlement a raconté par
tout ce weekend que ce texte allait
faire que le village du Père Noël en
Finlande allait être rasée on est parti
sur du délire au point que c'est devenu
vraiment des propos du un peu du
populisme d'extrême droite et c'est là
où c'est le bâton qui se fait bat
puisque cette victoire montre
l'opération mensongère d'une droite très
dure qui est venue chasser sur les
terres d'extrême droite avec
Q quel objectif justement de récupérer
un électorat notamment le lectorat un
peu conservateur
lectorat agricole et on voit bien à ce
niveau là et ça c'est terrible pour nous
on voit bien que c'est pas la nature
parce que ce loi cette loi pour la
première fois mais dans la loi le droit
de restaurer la nature vous rendez
compte ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que ces forêts qui sont qui ne poussent
plus on voit des lieux partout en Europe
ou c'est vraiment des écosystèmes qui
sont dégradés là on prend en compte le
fait qu'on va prendre des sûr de
restauration c'est une première dans
l'histoire allez de l'Europe et on
revient vers vous dans un instant Karima
délit donc les objectifs d'ici à 2030
restaurer 20% des terres et des eaux de
maritimes et d'ici à 2050 réparé tous
les écosystèmes dégradés je vais venir
vers vous mais il y a quand même une
charge assez lourde on entend populisme
vert Pascal confins il est allé très
loin il a même parlé de
climatossepticisme de trumpisme au
Parlement européen fake news qu'est-ce
que vous répondez mais c'est je dirais
la taxe facile aujourd'hui vous voulez
discréditer vous dites c'est l'extrême
droite c'est le populisme non la réalité
c'est que les membres du PPE ce que nous
défendons nous notamment en France les
républicains c'est le pragmatisme c'est
une écologie de bon sens et aujourd'hui
la réalité c'est qu'Emmanuel Macron
c'est allié avec l'extrême gauche avec
les écologistes pour nuire à notre
souveraineté alimentaire nationale et
nuire à nos agriculteurs ça c'est la
réalité
un texte pardon mais aujourd'hui sur le
zan la nonne artificialisation des sols
ils sont revenus en arrière parce
qu'aujourd'hui ça bloque beaucoup de
projets dans les communes et ils le
savent ça bloque des projets de
réindustrialisation verte et aujourd'hui
grâce au Sénat grâce au sénateurs LR il
y a un allégement de ce dispositif
en matière d'écologie c'est la question
de l'acceptabilité c'est la question fin
du mois fin du monde elle revient
systématiquement Anne-Claire Poirier
quand on regarde dans le détail la
Karima délit elle dit c'est très
important c'est symbolique etc mais en
fait le texte il a été quasiment vidé de
sa substance par le Conseil des
ministres les états par rapport à la
version de Soula vanderlion de la
Commission européenne n'en met que des
objectifs de moyens et non de résultats
il y a un gagnant ce soir alors c'est
vrai que on a quand même évite alors il
faut quand même signaler qu'on a évité
le pire à savoir un abandon total de la
loi et là là pour le coup ça aurait été
vraiment grave parce que sans cette loi
le green de enfin la neutralité il était
par terre c'était
on pouvait pas se passer parce que
l'atteindre de la neutralité carbone
elle dépend de cette loi quoi tout ce
qui est émission incompressible pour ne
pourra pas émettre on compte les stocker
dans les sols dans les arbres c'est ce
qu'on appelle les carbone cette loi elle
doit permettre ça de restaurer les
écosystèmes qui sont abîmés qui sont
très abîmés en Europe 70% des sols en
mauvais état
on peut quand même se féliciter d'avoir
sauvé les meubles c'est vrai que la loi
était bien en quoi elle est
contraignante alors justement elle est
contraignante déjà obligation moyen
c'est pas toujours le cas c'est une loi
qui est juridiquement contraignante
alors effectivement les obligations de
résultats ont été remplacées par des
obligations moyen donc c'est vrai qu'on
aura plus de mal à s'appuyer sur des
critères affectifs pour pour pénaliser
les États qui ne respecteront pas leur
leur objectif mais tout de même quand la
France par exemple respecte pas ses
objectifs d'énergie renouvelables ça lui
coûte 500 millions d'euros donc si on
constate en 2030 que la France n'a pas
mis en œuvre
les mesures nécessaires pour tenter en
tous les cas de restaurer 20% des
écosystèmes dégradés en France elle sera
pénalisée financièrement alors fait la
question de la résistance la résistance
des des populations qui s'est posée au
fond les les Etats se sont faits aussi
les porte-voix des peuples sur ces
affaires là quand vous regardez par
exemple le président de la République
française sur la question des normes
environnementales sur au fond les normes
à venir il a dit ça c'était le 11 mai
dernier écoutez
moi j'appelle à la pose réglementaire
européenne maintenant il faut qu'on
exécute il faut pas qu'on fasse de
nouveaux changements de règles parce
qu'on va perdre tous les acteurs donc on
a besoin de stabilité
Cécile clavérolle est-ce que là il y a
pas au fond des discours contradictoires
complètement complètement et ce que
disait donc ce texte a été vidé de son
contenu de sa substance avec on a le
texte qui a été voté on se félicite
qu'il a été voté mais maintenant il va
falloir
rétropédaler pour remettre dedans ce qui
a été enlevé par les différents
amendements mais ce ras-le-bol des
normes quand il en parle le chef de
l'État est-ce qu'il n'est pas au fond en
train de relayer ce que je voudrais dire
c'est des acteurs c'est que dans ce
texte il y avait la préservation des
terres agricoles qui a été enlevé il y
avait la préservation des océans les
océans c'est enfin on a en France vous
parliez des sols dégradés en Europe on a
en France 60% des autres surfaces qui ne
sont pas en bon état écologique comment
on va faire quand on ne pourra plus du
tout boire l'eau
au robinet d'accord comment on va faire
comment on va faire quand on ne pourra
plus produire parce qu'on a plus de
biodiversité dans les sols donc un
moment donné il va c'est pas la question
des normes c'est la question de se poser
la question quand est-ce qu'on est prêt
à changer parce qu'on a en face de nous
vraiment devant le nez c'est des filles
dont nous parlait et on peut pas le
faire sans les peuples mais c'est pas
pour ça que la démocratie d'ailleurs est
si importante et de ce vote c'est une
forme c'est une question de lobby c'est
une question
de lobby c'est pas une question de
peuple c'est eux qui ont fait pression à
votre avis sur le PPE la droite
l'extrême concrètement non
mais un autre argument c'est c'est de
dire exactement ce que dit Madame
non c'est le bon sens paysan vous savez
chez nous le bon sens paysan et
effectivement ce que dit le président de
la République et à proprement scandaleux
parce que ceux qui ont réussi à faire
vous êtes d'accord avec lui
manifestement
oui sur ce volet pour la suite pour
l'existant et le problème c'est qu'il
dit ça et il fait voter au Parlement
européen avec ses députés avec ses
députés européens des dispositifs qui
vont encore plus remettre de normes sur
les agriculteurs et ça c'est
problématique donc c'est son discours
dans même temps qui pose problème
national allemand c'est la même chose
sur le discours de l'eau et en fait là
aussi votre artifice d'utiliser les
peurs de faire peur aux populations ça
essaie de sa fonctionne parce que vous
faites craindre un peuple qui n'aura
plus d'eau qui n'aura plus rien à manger
mais la réalité c'est qu'aujourd'hui
c'est énorme feront que demain nous
irons à la crise alimentaire nous sommes
allés avec des propos tels que les
vôtres à la crise énergétique le 0% de
nucléaire c'est vous qui la portez c'est
vous qui l'avez porté et aujourd'hui on
voit le résultat les normes se
superposent à d'autres normes la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments le
DPE tous les propriétaires savent
aujourd'hui le TPE le DPE le
diagnostic pour établir les pertes
énergétiques ou non des bâtiments qui
aujourd'hui gel tout marché locatif du
logement ça ce sont des normes portées
aussi par des partisans tels que le
vôtre la fin du moteur thermique c'est
la même chose l'avènement de
l'électrique c'est exactement porté par
ce genre de on va faire réagir Karima
moi je voudrais simplement émettre parce
que le diagnostic aujourd'hui il est de
dire nous pouvons depuis la France
refaire la planète à 9 mais la réalité
c'est qu'aujourd'hui vous sabordez
l'agriculture la souveraineté
alimentaire européenne et de fait
national au profit de l'international et
au profit de pays qui aujourd'hui la
chinement ne tiennent pas compte de
dispositifs
et vous êtes dans une proposition de
valoriser la véritable la véritable
véritable combat aurait été les clauses
miroirs vous voyez qu'on arrête
le dispositif des produits
qu'on aurait dû mener allez Karima délit
vous êtes à distance c'est moins facile
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à votre
collègue des républicains c'est vrai
qu'on le voit les eaux d'affaires de
mission la question de
l'artificialisation on le voit le
problème de l'acceptabilité il se pose
et il se repose aussi avec les
agriculteurs et cet argument au fond on
va finir par devoir importer à des
Chinois qui eux polluent beaucoup plus
que nous
il y a plusieurs choses dans vos
questions d'abord je vous le dis il y a
eu un amendement sur les clauses du
miroir qui a été adopté ça c'est la
première chose
s'il vous plaît pour ceux qui nous
regardent et ensuite je tiens à vous
dire qu'il faut arrêter de dire tout et
son contraire pourquoi nous sommes là
tous réunis parce que justement la
véritable question normalement la
protection de la nature ne doit pas
diviser les gens
elle devrait tous quand on dit il faut
réparer les terres réparer les mers tout
le monde devrait être d'accord au fait
mais là on n'est pas d'accord sur tout
le monde n'est pas d'accord pourquoi
c'est parce que c'est il faut appliquer
des règles pourquoi il faut appliquer
les règles la véritable question c'est
parce qu'on a pris trop de retard madame
ditez tout à l'heure alors sur un
dossier que je connais très bien c'est
notamment la sortie des véhicules la fin
de la vente des véhicules thermiques
mais pourquoi vous pensez qu'on arrive
là madame vous savez pourquoi on arrive
là parce que on a eu du diesel gate en
France on a eu du diesel gate en
Allemagne ce sont des industries qui ont
15 ans de retard sur la Chine moi je
n'ai pas envie d'avoir des voitures
électriques chinoises en Europe mais
malheureusement on a bah oui mais parce
qu'on n'a pas pris le virage de la
transition atteint ben oui mais il faut
l'assumer quand même il faut l'assumer
aujourd'hui vous favoriser l'industrie
chinoise
mais c'est parce que développement
d'énergie renouvelable les panneaux
photovoltaïques aussi sont fabriqués en
Chine
depuis 15 ans ne veut pas faire la
transition
et je peux vous le dire puisque c'est
moi qui ai levé le lièvre sur la
question du diesel gate vous avez fait
en sorte qu'on reste dans les termites
qu'on reste dans les termes pendant que
d'autres pensées aux alternatives c'est
pour ça qu'on est dernier et à chaque
fois sur chaque problème l'agriculture
vous êtes en train de nous dire mais non
faut rester sur le statut quo bah oui et
en même temps vous êtes dans un dans un
problème terrible parce que vous
favorisez le libre-échange comment vous
donc en gros
nucléaire comment faites-vous pour
alimenter les véhicules électriques sans
nucléaire alors d'abord on ne dit pas
que comme ça parce que nous on est
réaliste on faisait pragmatiques
contrairement à vous on ne dit pas que
la voiture électrique déjà tout résoudre
on dit que c'était une de solution ça
c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose qui nous paraît intéressante c'est
toute cette question agricole parce que
vous nous êtes en train de nous dire oh
oui l'agriculture doit nourrir la
planète à nourrir la planète sauf
qu'aujourd'hui on vous signez dès demain
l'ensemble des traités de libre-échange
évidemment le mec posture etc alors vous
ouvrez tellement de sujets que c'est un
peu difficile de suivre on est passé de
la voiture électrique et du nucléaire à
la question ça fait beaucoup car il m'a
donné on va pas vous mettre d'accord de
toute façon entre les écologistes et les
républicains ce soir mais c'est
intéressant ce débat il est il est
fondamental parce que il est permanent
c'est la question du rapport au temps
au-delà de au-delà de ce de ce texte là
qui finalement a été voté on va terminer
ce débat on va aller à Strasbourg avec
François-Xavier Bellamy qui lui a
défendu sans succès ce texte Anne-Claire
Poirier vous savez qui a dit ça le temps
de la lutte contre le changement
climatique et le temps social pour le
rendre acceptable ne coïncide pas c'est
Daniel Cohn-Bendit
parmi les écologistes
qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire
moi je pense que si ça coïncide pas
c'est le résultat de choix politique qui
ont été faits je pense qu'on a mené des
politiques de fuite en avant pendant de
longues décennies et effectivement
aujourd'hui en 2023 quand le
réchauffement climatique frappe très
fort comme on l'a vu l'été dernier on a
plus le temps cela dit je pense quand
même que tout est tout est rattrapable
et en particulier c'est l'objet quand
même du Green Deal on parle des normes
mais on pourrait aussi parler du
financement cette loi elle va être
financée comment comment parce que le
budget européen quoi et ça va être
discuté de la fin de l'année d'ailleurs
combien de milliards c'est la paix
va compenser le plus gros budget et qui
finance et qui financent le décider que
le profil de décider la transition
agricole
et notamment la nouvelle Pâque elle est
de plus en plus contraignante
à l'ASSE international sur les contrôles
qui sont opérés dans les exploitations
agricoles et notamment les contrôles de
la PAC les agriculteurs et j'ai vu j'ai
vu les dossiers de Pâques j'ai vu ce qui
est exigé j'ai vu ce qui est exigé
notamment en matière de haie j'ai vu ce
qui est exigé en matière d'entretien et
de maintenir la biodiversité sur les
territoires et ça ce sont les
agriculteurs qui le font et donc ne
dites pas que la transition énergétique
n'est pas les financements c'est vrai
que pour l'instant la Pâques elle est
constante mais rien n'est prévu
justement par rapport à toutes ces
nouvelles normes des compensations etc
les quand vous parlez d'accompagnement
les financements seront au rendez-vous
pour les agriculteurs mais il suffit de
le décider politiquement c'est-à-dire de
réorienter les financements qui sont
aujourd'hui on a eu plus d'un milliard
d'euros près d'un milliard d'euros sur
le les différents plans écophytaux et
cofito ça voulait dire économiser les
phytos les produits phytosanitaires donc
ce qu'on appelle les pesticides plus
d'un milliard d'euros essentiellement
distribués aux Chambres d'agriculture
aux instituts techniques pour arriver à
plus 15% de produits utilisés c'est pas
de la Gadji mais vous voulez que du bio
en fait vous voyez le résultat
aujourd'hui du bio sur le territoire
aucun agriculteur ne veut faire de bio
parce qu'aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que vous proposez mais
qu'est-ce que vous proposez quoi de
ralentir le rythme simplement des
mesures de bons et le bon sens
et de s'appuyer sur la biodiversité
parce que c'est le vivant qui va nous
sauver mais pas les pesticides du vivant
les et qui sont aujourd'hui implantés
que vous défendez tant qui grâce à qui
sont-elles plantées
vraiment là c'est du gagnant gagnant
pour les agriculteurs ça vous le
reconnaissez ils n'ont aucun intérêt
vous parlez des produits phytos vous
croyez véritablement oui mais vous
parlez des produits phytos vous pensez
véritablement aujourd'hui qu'un
agriculteur au prix ou coûte les
intrants ils ont qu'une envie c'est
d'utiliser des intrants bien sûr que non
écoute excessivement très bien et
simplement il faut éviter les
interdictions sans alternative
aujourd'hui c'est ce que vous avez fait
avec les néonicotinoïdes avec le
glyphosate vous voulez faire une
écologie punitive pour sanctionner les
Français et ce à tout niveau des
agriculteurs en premier comme vous
l'avez vu la danse se débat vous êtes
qui est seul plutôt déséquilibré c'est
pour ça qu'on va terminer avec
François-Xavier Bellamy bonsoir monsieur
le député et merci d'être en duplex du
Parlement de Strasbourg vous avez
énormément défendus à votre contre ce
projet de loi c'est c'est donc une
défaite vous reconnaissez un échec ce
soir vous n'êtes pas parvenus à peser
avec le PPE avec les parties d'extrême
droite pour vous opposer à cette loi sur
la restauration de la nature
en effet à 12 fois prêts et je voudrais
quand même insister sur le fait que ce
qui se sont opposés à ce texte
appartiennent à plusieurs groupes
politiques y compris par exemple au
groupe in you ils sont nombreux dans le
groupe des macronistes d'autres
délégations nationales à avoir voté
contre ce texte donc il ne s'agit pas
d'une question de d'extrême droite comme
certains chez eux voulaient nous le
faire croire c'est en réalité un enjeu
qui dépasse de très loin les sujets de
politique politiciens puisque ce qui est
en jeu c'est effectivement de sauver la
nature et en réalité l'agenda qui nous
est proposé par ce texte va mettre en
danger non seulement notre économie nos
modèles sociaux notre capacité à
produire ce dont nous avons besoin mais
aussi la nature c'est-à-dire les
conséquences précises pour vous de du
vote de ce texte
la première des conséquences c'est que
ce texte organise un agenda de
décroissance pour l'Europe et notamment
de décroissance agricoles en effet il y
a dans ce texte des dispositions qui
l'étude d'impact de la Commission
européenne le reconnaît elle-même vont
faire baisser la production alimentaire
dans nos pays or nous continuons d'avoir
faim et nous allons évidemment continuer
de consommer des produits alimentaires
mais la différence c'est que nous allons
les faire venir du coup du reste du
monde c'est déjà le cas aujourd'hui nous
sommes devenus de plus en plus
dépendants de ces modes de production
qui à l'extérieur de l'Union européenne
ne respecte pas nos règles et par
conséquent font le plus de mal à
l'environnement et moi je suis révolté
pardon je suis révolté d'entendre à
l'instant sur votre plateau que les
agriculteurs n'ont pas changé en Europe
les agriculteurs respectent aujourd'hui
les règles environnementales les plus
exigeantes du monde en Europe et
Anne-Laure Blin a totalement raison de
dire que la Pâques est le premier levier
de cette transition si il faut
l'améliorer à leur travail en sur
l'impact mais ne multiplions pas les
couches réglementaires absurdes qui à la
fin vont que nous ne produirons plus
rien le jour où nous ne produiront plus
rien nous sommes peut-être très contents
de ne plus polluer du tout mais en
réalité la vérité c'est que nous
dépendrons entièrement de la production
chinoise indienne américaine qui elle
évidemment ne présente aucun scrupule
pour habiller l'environnement utilise
tous les intrants que nous nous refusons
à nous-mêmes utilise toutes les
techniques qui abîment l'environnement
c'est à la fin c'est cette production là
à laquelle nous faisons des cadeaux
dernière question François-Xavier
Bellamy il y a le fond du texte et vous
vous y opposez et puis il y a les
arrières pensées politiques il y a quand
même en ligne de mire les élections
européennes vous n'allez pas vous
arrêter là l'objectif c'est de parvenir
à l'union des droites c'est ça l'idée
encore une fois je le répète ce procès
est ridicule et il est complètement
décalé par rapport à la gravité des
enjeux depuis le début nous parlons du
fond du texte nous parlons des sujets de
fond nous parlons de ce qui va menacer
la forêt face aux incendies demain à
travers ce texte nous parlons de ce qui
menacera les pêcheurs nous parlons de ce
qui menacera l'industrie l'industrie
verte en Europe c'est que vous avez
changé les partenaires traditionnels de
compromis à Strasbourg le PPE s'est
tourné vers l'extrême droite c'est un
fait nous avons déposé notre amendement
de rejet parce que nous avons vu qu'il
était impossible de trouver des
compromis corrects sur ce sujet et ce
fait amendement de rejet il a été voté
effectivement par des députés qui
viennent de l'extrême droite par des
députés qui viennent du groupe
conservateur mais aussi je le redis par
des députés du groupe Rignoux le groupe
libéral auquel appartiennent les élus
d'Emmanuel Macron nous avons demandé
depuis des mois un moratoire législatif
pour cesser d’ache fixer sous
l'inflation normative tous ceux qui
produisent en Europe et Emmanuel Macron
reprend la même expression que nous
est-ce qu'on va nous faire un procès en
macronisme non
sur la pose réglementaire on s'arrête là
le problème c'est que les élus
macronistes ici ils font le travail des
verts et avec les verres et l'extrême
gauche et c'est ça la vraie coalition
qui menace la production européenne et
qui menace la nature ici la vraie
coalition qui met en danger l'équilibre
européen c'est celle qui associe les
députés macronistes avec l'extrême
gauche européenne et c'est ça que nous
combattons en effet et que nous
continuerons à combattre on va s'arrêter
là merci beaucoup François-Xavier et
l'ami d'avoir été en duplex depuis
Strasbourg on le voit c'était serré 12
mois seulement et non pas 36 je vous
prie de bien vouloir m'excuser pour
cette imprécision vous voulez avoir le
mot de la fin très rapidement on vous
avait préparé une petite carte en Europe
sur la montée des populismes il gouverne
la droite et l'extrême droite c'est le
cas en Finlande c'est le cas en Suède
c'est c'est une donne avec laquelle doit
compter aujourd'hui les Européens c'est
vrai que là on a vu quand même plusieurs
barrières tombées moi après moi sur
l'alliance effectivement enfin il y a
une tentation très forte de la droite
vers l'extrême droite jusqu'ici le
climat faisait partie des sujets qui
faisaient consensus à Bruxelles c'est
peut-être pas le cas en France mais à
Bruxelles le PPE jusqu'à récemment
soutenez le
la présidente de la Commission
européenne représente le PPE elle porte
le Green Deal et elle le porte
vaillamment non là il y a vraiment eu
une barrière qui est tombée on a décidé
de sacrifier le climat sur l'hôtel de
l'électoralisme ça c'est clair ouais
merci on s'arrête là on sent bien que ce
débat voilà il va continuer sur
prolonger forcément merci à vous d'être
venu sur LCB vous restez avec moi Julien
godicheau va parler de votre livre mais
dans une dizaine de minutes on va
retrouver les parties pris de nos
affranchis ce soir on accueille fftel de
libération qui s'interroge pourquoi le
gouvernement n'implique pas dans la
reconstruction les jeunes condamnés par
la justice pendant les émeutes Fanny
guinnochet de France Info s'est penché
elle sur le casse-tête budgétaire du
gouvernement et puis d'un Bourbon
express de quoi nous parlez-vous
Stéphanie despiat on parlera du recours
très important voire trop important de
l'État au cabinet de conseil privé à
tout à l'heure mesdames on plonge
d'abord dans votre livre je le disais ça
fait des années qu'on en parle de ces
campements de migrants de la jungle de
Calais de la Côte d'Opale au départ vous
n'imaginiez pas y rester si longtemps
sept ans de votre vie une longue enquête
qui commence en 2015 avec des scènes
surréalistes ou tous les jours des
femmes des enfants des hommes risquent
leur vie on en parle tous les deux juste
après l'invitation signée ce soir par
Maïté vraiment
si on vous invite Julien Goody show
c'est pour nous parler de ces trajets
dit qui se répètent dans nos eaux et sur
nos rivages en Méditerranée dans
l'Atlantique ou encore dans la Manche
ces traversées dorment de femmes et
d'enfants abordent d'embarcation de
fortune de leurs rêves d'ailleurs quitte
à y laisser leur vie ce matin encore 200
personnes étaient portées disparues au
large de l'archipel des Canaries en
Espagne
3500 km plus au nord cap vers la Côte
d'Opale ou l'Angleterre n'est plus qu'à
40 km là ou 45000 migrants ont risqué la
traverser l'année dernière on vient
faire notre randonnée le dimanche on
vient se balader donc il fait soleil on
se balade et puis là tout d'un coup au
détour d'un chemin on voit 50 personnes
surgir en train de hurler avec des
gilets de sauvetage en train de porter
des bébés dans les bras et vous portez
surtout un énorme Cano à bout de bois
bout de bras arrivé en haut d'une et se
jeter dans l'eau
et en s'entassant à l'intérieur de ce
morceau de caoutchouc dans votre ouvrage
les plages de l'embarquement une enquête
de 235 pages vous y racontez vos 7
années passées au contact des migrants
venus d'Érythrée d'Irak d'Iran ou encore
de Syrie vous y relatez également ces
passeurs qui assurent la traversée vers
l'Angleterre un business dites-vous ou
une place dans une embarcation de
fortune coûte 1500 euros organisation
mafieuse qui raquette et qui règle leurs
comptes entre elles avec des armes
Julien goudicheau vous êtes journaliste
indépendant réalisateur de documentaires
ce qui vous passionne ce sont les
grandes enquêtes de société votre caméra
et votre regard se posent sur les
démunis et les oubliés de notre
territoire ce soir on s'interroge Julien
godicho le mois dernier le monde entier
s'est tenu des passagers disparus du
sous-marin parti observer l'épave du
Titanic alors qu'au même moment
des centaines de migrants mourraient en
Méditerranée comment analyser vous cette
indifférence
[Musique]
votre réponse je viens Goody show
malheureusement tous ces gens qui
meurent en Méditerranée aujourd'hui ce
sont devenus des articles des brèves des
choses que l'on lit ou on apprend des
chiffres aujourd'hui c'est les parents
on a pris il y a pas longtemps qui
étaient une centaine une centaine de
personnes à cette noyée à avoir couler
donc on en parle beaucoup on lit des
articles insupportables pour vous bien
sûr comment on pourrait ne pas
s'indigner face à de tel chiffre alors
c'est mes grands venus d'Afrique venus
du Moyen-Orient ont connu déjà un
périple des années extrêmement
difficiles d'errance avant d'arriver en
France sur ses côtes que vous avez voilà
arpenté dans tous les sens ils
connaissent le risque de la noyade ils
le savent parfaitement et il tente et il
retente
comment vous expliquer qu'ils arrivent à
prendre ce risque là à payer ce prix là
[Musique]
alors racontez-nous parce que c'est les
chiffres sont saisissants il y a cinq
ans il n'y avait que quelques centaines
de départs on est à 45000 départs chaque
cette année pour traverser la Manche
qu'est-ce qui se passe vous commencez on
vous entendez sur France Inter raconter
la dune à Dunkerque qu'est-ce qui se
passe quand en plein jour il y a des
groupes de gens qui se précipitent pour
aller sur des petits bouts de caoutchouc
des zodiacs de fortune racontez-nous
bien sûr mais maintenant il y a des
zones dans le carquois qui sont
magnifiques qui sont des dunes ou les
familles viennent en randonnée les gens
viennent promener leur chien et s'y
promener le dimanche mais maintenant à
tout moment on peut voir sortir des
dizaines et des dizaines de personnes en
portant un bateau à bout de bras pour
arpenter ses dunes en côtoyant toutes
ces personnes pour finir par se jeter
dans l'eau en hurlant en portant leurs
enfants à bout de bras parfois avec un
bébé dans un sac de tomber à l'eau
exactement des femmes des enfants que
l'on protège tant bien que mal comme
l'on peut et c'est devenu des scènes que
les gens les gens assistes bon ben on se
ressent le téléphone portable pour
immortaliser la scène pour ramener des
souvenirs de vacances et puis de toute
façon c'est tellement choquant
ça donne envie de prendre en photo pour
en parler autour de le train les camions
sous la Manche ça il y en a beaucoup
moins vous confirmez pourquoi on a le
périmètre pour le train a été vraiment
très sécurisé militarisé donc c'est
quasiment impossible de monter sur un
train aujourd'hui pour arriver en
Angleterre les camions c'est très
compliqué mais le pourcentage existe
encore il est très faible et c'est pour
ceux qui n'ont plus d'argent pour
arriver à passer en Angleterre dans un
camion c'est des nuits toutes les nuits
c'est des nuits à rassantes et puis au
bout de six mois huit mois un an on
finit par y arriver donc maintenant le
bateau c'est une fois sur deux sur trois
ça passe et on arrive en Angleterre donc
alors décrivez-nous c'est un business
c'est d'ailleurs plus qu'un business
très lucratif c'est une organisation
mafieuse hyper structurée du bas de
l'échelle au haut de l'échelle comment
ça s'organise
alors en l'espace de trois ans c'est une
organisation qui a explosé parce que
c'est des ça a commencé sur des petits
canaux au départ les migrants
s'organisaient eux-mêmes ils achetaient
sur le bon coin ils achetaient un moteur
par-ci un petit bateau par là et puis
arrivé puis ils se mettent à l'eau il
traversait il payait un chauffeur pour
emmener le bateau et puis ils arrivent à
partir du moment où ça a marché le
message est passé ils se sont dit il y a
un truc à faire il y a certains de ces
passeurs qui sont rien d'autre que
d'anciens migrants qui sont passés qui
ont connu cette guerre là pour traverser
la mer qui se sont dit on va aider les
suivants et donc aider les suivants
c'est la logistique pour acheminer un
bateau le faire venir qui est neuve
d'ailleurs en l'espace de trois ans au
début c'était 10 personnes dans un
bateau aujourd'hui c'est 50 personnes
dans un bateau pour une rentabilité
multipliée par quatre ou cinq tentez si
bien qu'aujourd'hui les bateaux sont
commandés en Chine sont acheminées par
container jusqu'en Turquie ou en
Allemagne et puis après on paye des
petites mains des personnes que l'on
recrute pour convoyer ces bateaux ne
sont plus là
ne sont plus là avant il n'est sur la
plage maintenant ils sont cachés ils
ouvrent le portefeuille à distance de
temps en temps ils viennent mais c'est
devenu très pyramidal il y a un livreur
il y a un recruteur il y a un espèce de
manageur des passagers et puis
finalement les gens qui mettent les
bateaux à la mer que l'on appelle bien
souvent les passeurs ne sont rien
d'autre que des migrants même qui
travaillent à gonfler le bateau et
l'assemblée et à mettre les passagers
dedans pour pouvoir eux aussi pouvoir
gagner une place dans ce bateau et
arriver en Angleterre gratuitement et
dans tout ce tissu mafieux dans ce
business il y a beaucoup d'armes il y a
des gens qui seront tirés dessus en
plein jour c'est ça alors c'est pareil
au bout de depuis un an ou deux ben
c'est un business qui a fait tellement
d'argent que forcément c'est groupe
c'est mafia ce sont enrichis et donc il
faut se protéger parce que c'est quelque
chose qui attire les convoitises quand
on fait beaucoup d'argent et on parle de
plusieurs millions pour certains
passeurs il y a des règlements de compte
il y a des règlements de compte c'est à
dire que une plage appartient à un
passeur si quelqu'un doit devient tout
simplement sur la même place de spasteur
envoyer des bateaux ça va faire des
problèmes alors vous avez fait le choix
de la tenter vous aussi la traversée
pourquoi cette décision et comment ça
s'est déroulée
j'ai suivi des tas de personnes que j'ai
commencé à filmer pendant ces années
rencontré dans les camps qui me faisait
confiance qui me laissait les filmer
dans des situations et des états ils
avaient honte c'est jamais très
gratifiant de se faire filmer les pieds
dans la boue et d'être
réduit à ça un animal on peut le dire
oui on peut le dire en condition animale
on vivait des tas de choses et puis nos
routes se séparer avant ces embarcations
avant cet embarquement voilà donc des
fois j'ai perdais les personnes j'avais
pas le droit de les accompagner sur la
plage vous pouvez pas appuyer je pense
qu'au terme de toutes ces années j'avais
besoin moi aussi de terminer ce voyage
avec eux et de documenter ce qui se
passe réellement dans un bateau on
parlait tout à l'heure de chiffres dans
la Méditerranée souvent on entend des
histoires de migrants on voit des
reportages on les voit dans les tentes
on les voit dans la chambre mais on se
dit bon d'accord c'est un phénomène qui
existe c'est malheureusement quand on
voit des gens qui s'entassent réellement
dans un bateau qui prend l'eau et que
l'on doit écoper en train de crier et
prier pour leur vie je pense qu'on
percute un petit peu plus vous savez
qu'on est à l'Assemblée nationale les
fameuses accords du tout quai sont
souvent remise en cause Gérald Darmanin
voulait mettre à mal complètement en
fait ce qui se passe c'est que c'est la
France qui gère pour l'Angleterre la
frontière
vous avez parlé à des quarts de côtes en
échange d'une indemnisation financière
les garde de côte pour les anglais
décident d'empêcher les passages comment
ils vivent ça concrètement sur le
terrain les garde de côte
je pense que c'est compliqué pour eux
après maintenant les bateaux sont
arrêtés
en bord de mer la police fait mais tous
les moyens en oeuvre pour éviter que le
bateau touche l'eau les passeurs le
savent très bien les passeurs organisent
en voyage ils le disent aux migrants ils
nous l'avait dit d'ailleurs quand on est
en haut de la lune de ça on voit la
police elle est pas loin elle a une
centaine de mètres la police est là
courez le plus vite possible une fois
que vous avez touché l'eau que vous êtes
dans l'eau c'est fini vous êtes en
sécurité vous avez juste à démarrer le
moteur et on vous a un drapeau vous
embêter sur l'eau vous arriverez à aller
en Angleterre si tu avais une un titre
de séjour sur les fameux métiers en
tension dont on parle il y a un projet
de loi immigration on verra ce qu'il
resterait ou pas
un titre séjour ici pour travailler ici
bien sûr il resterait l'obsession de
l'Angleterre n'est pas à ce prix elle
n'est pas définitive il y en a plein qui
partent et qui me disent je suis bien
ici j'aime bien les gens en France
j'aime ce pays il est beau j'ai été bien
accueilli mais malheureusement on peut
pas travailler la dernière fois qu'on
m'a dit ça c'est simple c'était sur le
bateau de secours des Anglais qui nous
ont récupérés dans notre morceau de
caoutchouc qui prenait l'eau de toutes
parts on est monté dans le bateau on a
vu les côtes anglaises on allait
accoster puis ce monsieur iranien qui
était avec moi qui s'est mis à grimacé
qui m'a dit mais je sais pas pourquoi je
vais là-bas il fait froid il fait pas
j'aime pas trop ce pays j'étais bien en
France mais malheureusement chez vous on
nous donne pas de travail et j'ai besoin
de gagner de l'argent et commencer ma
vie voilà on verra ce qui est en strate
ce projet de loi en attendant si vous
voulez vous rendre compte de ce que
c'est que cette vie cette enfer que vive
ces gens les plages de l'embarquement
c'est à dire c'est donc co-écrit avec
Nicolas Torin aux éditions Les Arènes je
vous propose de rester avec moi c'est
l'heure d'accueillir nous affranchis
leur parti pris vont vous faire réagir
on les accueille tout de suite encore
femme et c'est tant mieux ce soir
bienvenue
Eve shephtel de libération Fanny
guinochet de France Info à tout de suite
pour vos cartes blanches on commence
comme chaque soir par Bourbon Express
l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée c'est
vous qui nous la racontez Stéphanie
bonsoir Stéphanie Despierre bonsoir
alors c'est l'histoire Myriam ce soir
des relations entre l'État et les
cabinets de conseils privés
rappelez-vous l'hiver dernier le Sénat
lance une commission d'enquête et en
pleine campagne présidentielle sort son
rapport aux vitriol l'île dénonce un
recours bien trop important à ses
cabinets privés par les ministères un
phénomène tentaculaire Emmanuel Macron
était épinglé pour sa proximité avec des
grands noms du conseil comme McKinsey ça
empoisonnera toute la campagne du
président de la République et la justice
ouvrira même deux enquêtes un an plus
tard c'est la Cour des comptes qui rend
sa copie c'était lundi et les chiffres
sont éloquents les dépenses hors
informatiques sont passées de 11
millions d'euros en 2014 à 233 millions
d'euros en 2021 et elles ont même
lors du premier quinquennat d'Emmanuel
Macron entre 2017 et 2022 alors certes
il a fallu le renfort du privé pour
gérer la crise sans précédent du covid
mais la Cour des comptes accuse
carrément l'état d'avoir parfois laissé
ses prestataires privés prendre le pas
sur les hauts fonctionnaires et décider
à leur place alors une circulaire
ministérielle à ni le hola en janvier
2022 ce que reconnaît la Cour des
comptes en 2022 les dépenses
ralentissent mais le président de la
cour appelle quand même à clarifier les
règles
il nous semble qu'il faut encore aller
plus loin et que nous n'avons pas tout à
fait fini avec le sujet parce que on ne
connaît pas encore suffisamment bien le
phénomène parce qu'il y a pas assez de
transparence sur les chiffres alors
comment on concrètement aller plus loin
comme le veut le président de la Cour
des comptes alors le Sénat a voté une
loi à la quasi unanimité mi-octobre il
ne s'agit pas à d'interdire l'usage de
ces camionnette conseil pour
l'administration mais de mieux
l'encadrer mais le texte attend depuis 8
mois d’être étudié à l'Assemblée et à
l'Assemblée alors qu'est-ce qui se passe
sur les cabinets de conseils alors
l'assemblée est un peu raté le train du
débat il faut dire que le camp
présidentiel n'a pas forcément envie de
se pencher sur le sujet alors les
députés essayent de se rattraper un peu
cet après-midi Marie le bec pour
Renaissance et Nicolas sangsue pour les
communistes on présentait les
conclusions de leur mission flash qui
étudie les relations entre cabinet de
conseils et cette fois collectivités
locales alors ils sont tous deux
d'accord pour dire qu'il faut aussi
réglementer les deux parlementaires
estiment qu'il faut une étude en
revanche plus approfondie pour obtenir
des chiffres et c'est là que les avis
divergent car pour Marie lebe il faut
prendre le temps et il faut une seule et
même loi pour l'État le gouvernement les
collectivités locales Nicolas sans su
lui veut deux textes car surtout il veut
que l'assemblée étudie cette fameuse
proposition de loi du Sénat et il a peur
que ce thème des collectivités locales
servent de prétexte problème c'est que
on a encore perdu deux mois
il faudrait pas qu'on en perte 6 6 mois
8 mois de plus ou un an de plus en
attendant le résultat sur les
collectivités territoriales je pense que
c'est pas raisonnable et que c'est même
dangereux pour pour ce que ce que pense
nos concitoyens vous savez
l'affaire McKinsey a fait grand bruit
elle a fait du mal à tout le monde
je crois que on peut pas se permettre
une autre affaire de ce type avant que
la proposition de loi soit votée et je
crois que ce serait bien que le
gouvernement entendent que y compris
pour lui c'est bien de montrer que on
agit vraiment sur la question de la
transparence et le recours au cabinet de
conseil privé
alors il n'y a pas que la gauche Myriam
tous les groupes d'opposition réclament
cette proposition de loi du Sénat mais
pour l'instant rien ne bouge elle n'est
toujours pas à l'agenda ici
vos opposants vous accusent de vouloir
enterrer cette proposition là du Sénat
alors il y a pas de volonté d'enterrer
ce texte de loi parce que déjà le
gouvernement bien avant même les
conclusions de la commission d'enquête
et du passage de la loi avaient pris des
dispositions pour rationaliser le
recours au cabinet de conseils alors en
coulisse certains dans l'état major de
renaissance disent que la proposition de
loi des sénateurs et mal écrites avec
des dispositions inapplicables mais face
aux pressions de toutes parts du Sénat
de la Cour des comptes des députés et
d'une partie des citoyens la majorité
s'interrogent elles ne pourra peut-être
pas faire l'économie d'une loi sur ses
cabinets de conseils voilà parfois la
pression même des oppositions fines par
payer on verra ce qu'il en est sur sur
ce texte ou pas merci beaucoup Stéphanie
on enchaîne avec vous Eve de libération
fftel vous vouliez nous parler ce soir
de ce qui va occuper les députés ça sera
le dernier projet de loi à l'Assemblée
dans l'hémicycle le projet de loi
d'urgence sur la reconstruction des
bâtiments des bâtiments dégradés ou même
détruits par les nuits des meutes vous
nous dites
ok quoi
avec ce projet de loi le gouvernement
donne l'impression encore une fois de ne
s'intéresser qu'aux bâtiment ou avant
tout au bâtiment et pas à ce pas assez à
ceux qui vivent dans ces quartiers et
quitte à faire revenir les sénateurs et
les députés de vacances pourquoi ne pas
aller plus loin tout de suite dans la
réponse aux émeutes regardez quand on
interroge des Français sur la solution
pour régler les problèmes des banlieues
c'est le
texte de la question leur réponse est
sans équivoque 59% sont pour la fermeté
25% seulement pour le dialogue selon un
sondage Opinionway donc personne ne
suggère de sortir le carnet de chèques
non le moment non non la dame la demande
d'ordre est très nette alors que la
crise de l'autorité au sens large du
terme apparaît de plus en plus comme la
cause principale de ses émeutes mais
pourquoi ne pas imaginer une autre
réponse qui a lirait la nécessité de la
reconstruction avec celle d'une sanction
qui soit éducative qui offrirait à ceux
qui ont participé aux violences la
possibilité de réparer leur bêtises
c'est mieux que de les envoyer en prison
semble-t-il
autrement dit pourquoi ne pas imaginer
de flécher les amandes ou les travaux
d'intérêt général les fameux tigres vers
les travaux de reconstruction alors
est-ce que c'est une piste qui est
étudiée par le gouvernement et bien oui
figurez-vous que certains dans l'homme
dans la majorité ils ont pensé ont même
suggéré justement de profiter de la
fenêtre de tir de ce projet de loi
reconstruction pour lier les deux sujets
reconstruction et réparation symboliques
et alors comme quoi on le sait pas qui
est un ministre ça aurait changé la
nature de ce projet de loi on aurait pu
été seulement sur l'urgence derrière on
ouvrait la porte de la justice on aurait
des amendements sur la responsabilité
parentale etc bref il m'a dit c'est pas
un sujet pour un 20 juillet même si
c'est très légitime mais c'est dommage
parce que c'est une occasion manquée et
on ne sait pas si elle va se reproduire
en attendant le risque de voir un jour
comme l'avait dit Gérard Collomb de
France vivre face à face et n'a jamais
été aussi grand et un autre ministre
vous allez deviner peut-être qui
formulait le même diagnostic la même
année en 2018 il est clair que l'écart
des chances d'A selon les territoires
les origines sociales ne cessent de
croître il ajoutait il ne s'agit plus de
comprendre d'expliquer encore moins
d'excuser leur état l'action au nom de
la solidarité nationale et en raison de
l'immense gâchis que représente pour le
pays cette jeunesse sacrifiée les mots
sont forts et ils sont de j'ai lu alors
je sais je vous laisse le dire et c'est
l'introduction de son fameux rapport qui
s'appelait vivre ensemble vivre en grand
pour une réconciliation nationale la
réconciliation nationale c'est aussi un
chantier qui ne peut pas attendre et
aurait mérité peut-être un projet loi
d'urgence en voilà un parti pris faire
participer les jeunes mineurs qui ont
participé aux violences à la
reconstruction ou même à quelques
actions symboliques par exemple dans les
écoles ça c'est une idée à votre avis
une bonne idée
on verra ce qu'il en est puisque le
président de la République ne parlera
pas finalement le 14 juillet patience
donc on termine avec vous Fanny Guinot
chez le gouvernement planche on le sait
sur son budget 2024 le marathon
commentaires c'est à l'automne prochain
c'est un casse-tête il faut faire 15
milliards d'euros d'économie fait
l'objectif que c'est fixé le
gouvernement et effectivement c'est
assez ambitieux alors il y a déjà
dévoilé quelques pistes par exemple
Bruno Le Maire le ministre de l'Économie
a déjà dit que par exemple le bouclier
tarifaire sur l'électricité à les
certainement diminuer que côté santé il
y aurait la traque aux arrêts maladie
les arrêts maladie de complaisance côté
logement c'est la fin du dispositif
Pinel vous savez ce système qui permet
de de faire l'investissement locatif
tout en faisant baisser ses impôts c'est
en faisant de la défiscalisation et qui
coûte quand même deux milliards d'euros
par an à l'état le gouvernement estime
que ça n'est pas efficace et puis côté
entreprise c'est un peu nouveau mais
quand même le Bruno Le Maire a dit
c'était ce weekend on rencontre
économique d'Aix que bah il fallait
qu'elle patiente un peu parce que il a
l'air réduire les avantages fiscaux
autour du gazole non routier le GNR ça a
l'air un peu complexe mais quand même
c'est le effectivement l'agriculture qui
l'utilise qu'il allait aussi décaler la
suppression d'un impôt de production qui
s'appelle un peu un mot barbare mais
CVAE la contribution de la valeur
ajoutée des entreprises et les
entreprises attendaient la fin de cette
impôt qui devait normalement se terminer
en 2024 et bien il fait ça sera
certainement repoussé donc les baisses
d'impôts dont on nous a un peu parlé
pour les classes moyennes tout ça c'est
plus tard pour les classes moyennes non
il continue à nous dire que il y aurait
quelques baisses d'impôts on est bien
bien bien loin du super plan Marshall
que Gabriel Attal le ministre des
comptes publics annonçait il y a encore
quelques semaines là c'est devenu ça
c'est réduit comme peau de chagrin ça
sera des baisses d'impôts très ciblés
probablement très limitées sur les les
plus modestes et en fait Gabriel Attal
parle plutôt d'efforts à faire plutôt
que de cadeaux ou en tout cas de d'aide
fiscale des efforts pour réduire la date
aussi et c'est la grande peur du
gouvernement parce que cette dette elle
pèse elle pèse de plus en plus lourde
tout le monde a ce chiffre qu'on a
dépassé 3000 milliards d'euros de dettes
et la crainte c'est que à cause de cette
dette qui s'amplifie et bien les agences
de notation
sanctionnent la France alors le
gouvernement se défendent de faire de
l'austérité alors que déjà les
oppositions l'accusent de passer par
cette voix vous voyez la bataille du
budget ne fait que commencer et à
l'Assemblée il y a encore quelque chose
pourri ça dépend où on se place que ça
passe par un
49.39
que vous saurez tout sur le budget quand
on voit tout ce qu'il faut financer ça
semble un peu compliqué merci mesdames
Merci à VOUS Julien Goudi show les
plages de l'embarquement j'ai passé 7
ans avec les migrants et les passeurs
dans le nord de la France c'est-à-dire
aux éditions Les Arènes très belle
soirée sur LCP soirée documentaire avec
Jean-Pierre Gratien bien sûr à demain
[Musique]